daniel wir hatten ja dieses thema schon
sehr oft die not der künstler wie sieht
es da bei dir aus hast du jetzt wieder
auftritte aktuell keine auftritte
ich habe werden der gründerzeit versucht
über andere tätigkeiten geld zu
verdienen also sprich ich habe mit
wendigkeit angenommen leben eben bei und
schneider videos für leute damit ich
einfach ein bisschen finanziell über die
runden kommen kommt denn da so viel rum
es reicht um über die runden zu kommen
du lachst das ist toll du hattest im
letzten jahr einen auftritt bei einer
dinner-show und wartet noch auf dein
geld was da passiert ich habe andere
monate bei einer dinner show mitgemacht
und eigentlich ja alles zur
zufriedenheit bewältigen abgeschlossen
und hat dann eigentlich endet es darum
meine gage bekommen sollen
hab dann anfang januar glaube ich ein
teil bekommen eine kleine rate und jetzt
danach nichts mehr habe dann über einen
anwalt beauftragt dass es regeln möchte
dass alle sich mit dem veranstalter in
verbindung setzt aber hat dann auch gar
keine antwort bekommen und das geld ist
nach wie vor nicht da was hast du
gemacht hast du moderiert oder hast du
gesungen ich habe gesungen
ich habe gesungen ich war teil des
onkels und hab da gesungen über 16 shows
waren es glaube ich
und ja lief alles gut ist halt auf die
tatsache dass ich dass wir nicht
entlohnt wurde
aber das ist ziemlich bitter 16 schoss
da geht es ja wahrscheinlich um eine
menge geld oder es geht um troja es gibt
also für mich ist es auf jeden fall eine
menge geld ja da muss ich doch gleich
mal unseren anwalt dazu nehmen an
kempkens daniel schuhmacher ist
aufgedreht sogar 16 mal in einer dinner
show und bekommt da jetzt nicht sein
geld wie sehen sie die lage ist
natürlich total ärgerlich da muss man
ganz grundsätzlich muss man hier den
schuldner in verzug setzen das heißt man
setzt der zahlungsfrist dann macht man
das an und danach sollte man sofort
klage einreichen
ich bin gar nicht so ein fan davon immer
wieder hin und her zu schreiben sondern
da muss man einfach brutal vorgehen denn
der erste der kommt der wird auch noch
geld bekommen denn wir haben vielfach
auch in insolvenz problem und da sollte
man möglichst schnell handeln damit man
vollstreckbaren titel kommt bekommt und
daraus dann gegebenenfalls auch
vollstrecken
kann man denn da vielleicht in künstler
verträgen von vornherein darauf drängen
dass vielleicht früher gezahlt werden
muss dass vielleicht ein abschlag
gezahlt wird er vielleicht vor ende
dieser 16 shows absolut und das ist auch
gar nicht unüblich wir haben ja sonst
auch oftmals eine barzahlung vor ort
dann wo man eben dann muss man ihm
quittiert wird und dass eben angerechnet
wird und das ist auch eine möglichkeit
um schon mal was zu bekommen man kann
auch vorauszahlungen machen aber das
problem ist natürlich dass bei den
agenturen durchzusetzen nicht alle
machen das aber man sollte das unbedingt
mal ansprechen und wenn man schon merkt
überhaupt keine bereitschaft zu
dann sollte man schon ein bisschen
skeptisch sein denn allen muss doch klar
sein dass der künstler auch geld braucht
und der künstler muss planen der
künstler hat ein repertoire das reporter
muss gepflegt werden
und der künstler der ständige ausgaben
und dass das nicht so einfach
funktioniert das man erst am ende
deshalb wird für seinen großen vertrag
und dann leer ausgeht ist ja ein
absolutes unding unverschämtheit findet
und verschiedenster sagt unser anwalt
wie war das denn als es losging war
schon von vornherein klar oder oder
warst du dir sicher dass du eigentlich
dein geld bekommst oder hattest du schon
während der veranstaltung schon deine
zweifel
ich hatte selbst ist ja schon mal sofort
das ist ja schon mal gemacht und da hat
alles funktioniert deswegen war das auch
einfach ein vertrauensvorschuss weil
eigentlich heftigsten raten gekommen
sondern eigentlich wöchentlich bezahlt
werden sollen aber das im letzten jahr
alles funktioniert hat das im jahr davor
war das einfach ein vertrauensvorschuss
und ich dachte mir dass wirbt während
weil ich habe mich eigentlich in der
schule finanziert weil ich hatte immer
eine gewisse anzahl von fans für mich
gekommen sind und dachte nicht dass
deswegen auch kein thema wäre auch was
was die tatsache betrifft dass ich
relativ früh bezahlt werde weil ich
glaube es geht ich bin nicht der einzige
könnte dennoch nicht bezahlt wurde
und das macht natürlich jetzt auch
schwieriger und war die show letztlich
ein erfolg oder blieben da vielleicht
sitzplätze leer das deswegen vielleicht
da so ein bisschen geldnot im spiel ist
die show war eigentlich gut besucht also
dass daran kann es ganz witzig scheitern
aber jetzt seine genauen zahlen wir was
er jetzt verdient hat oder was er nicht
verdient hat das weiß ich nicht aber das
ist ja auch als veranstalter wenn er das
risiko eingeht nicht meine sorge ein
ich habe meine leistung gebracht absolut
das dauern wird wahrscheinlich bestens
und jetzt hast du ein anwalt
eingeschaltet was ist im moment der
aktuelle stand der angehalten hat ihm
ein paar schreiben geschickt und er hat
darauf reagiert und dann habe ich
natürlich auch liquidität der firma
gecheckt und die es ihren roten bereich
das hat alles schwieriger gemacht also
ich hab ich wurde immer wieder
vertröstet ich habe jetzt wieder letzte
nachricht bekommen dass es geld jetzt
mitte september kommen sondern darauf
hoffe ich jetzt einfach weil das heißt
doch immer wo nichts zu holen das kann
man die zahlen
man weiß das nicht letzte frage daher zu
dem thema an ankämpft kannst kann ich
als künstler irgendwie absehen dass
vielleicht die firma oder der manager
vielleicht in den roten zahlen ist
wieder nicht eben gesagt hat also man
sollte sich nicht hinhalten lassen das
müsste ganz klar sagen die künstler oder
überhaupt auch alle gläubiger sind
oftmals etwas zurückhaltend weil man
geht ja davon aus dass man vielleicht im
nächsten jahr noch miteinander zu tun
hat und dann lässt man sich auch so
ausreden ein und dann wird oftmals auch
gesagt ja wir haben das geld schon
angewiesen unsere bank hatte irgendwas
falsch gemacht oder die buchhaltung ist
im urlaub oder irgendwie so dass am
wochenende nicht da und am montag nicht
gekommen und so weiter da sind alle
ausflüchte erfahrungsgemäß sollte man
sich auf keinen fall einlassen denn man
muss echt sagen den letzten beißen dann
oft nur noch die hunde mit der folge
dass man dann leer ausgeht dass
schnelligkeit angesagt und bitte nicht
ganz so viel hin und her schreiben
sondern wirklich dann druck machen
mahnverfahren das ist auch finanziell
überschaubar übrigens oder eben das
klageverfahren und dann wird man eben
sehen ob da noch was zu holen ist
tatsächlich wenn aber nichts mehr zu
holen ist es natürlich total blöd dass
weiß ich dann schmeißt man sozusagen
schlechtem geld gutes noch hinterher und
das muss man genau abwägen
absolut also wir hören sehr oft
tatsächlich jetzt die krone krise trifft
die künstler doch ganz schön und
deswegen klar ärgert es natürlich auch
daniel dass er das seinem geld
hinterherlaufen muss wann glaubst du da
die wann geht es wieder weiter hast du
neue projekte sind neue einnahmen in
sicht ich gebe eigentlich aktuell er aus
ich deswegen arbeite ich auch nebenbei
an
wie gesagt diese
oder auch schneidet videos für andere
leute weil ich neue single rausbringen
und das ist natürlich auch geld und ich
habe keine ahnung ich kann es gar nicht
einschätzen wann das finde ich jetzt
wieder wieder weitergeht mit auftritten
macht sie da so künftig alles vonstatten
gehen kann dann muss man einfach
abwarten und irgendwie versuchen
geduldig zu sein und versuchen irgendwie
wie gesagt wie erwähnt haben schon über
die runden zu kommen
italien vielen dank dass du so oft mit
dieser sendung darüber gesprochen hast
ich wünsche dir alles gute das so
vielleicht aber ende doch noch geld
siehst wir drücken da wirklich die
daumen